hello and welcome to this video don't
fool junseo okay i get some g6 stuff
again had the pills right before that
okay
it's not the most common move order
and maybe here I can actually stop b5
maybe he just wants to set up a hit
hippopotamus anyway maybe I'm not sure
if he wanted to do it like in the first
place but it is almost always like a
fallback option for black endures g6
based based setups Queen e1 has the idea
to push f5 which is not sure
and five maybe you take selfie txf
Bishop f3 and then taking on g4 is
actually possible you know maybe this is
just like a teen waiting move really
that looks weird why can you do that
isn't d5 good for white I don't quite
believe this but
195 first was also interesting
he's got c4 but I kind of just assumed
that is that this is too much like c4
Bishop takes Knight c2 but I don't
believe this
really if I get to take on e6 that looks
that looks like too dangerous
yeah what is he doing here
I mean we can somehow somehow shoot for
long castling
I don't know it's taking a long time
which is kind of understandable
this is certainly critical I really
don't know what you should do okay this
one mmm yeah I think I just [ __ ] well
95 was always the point against stuff
like that yeah let's do it
I mean against stuff like that I meant
when I get a porn on if and f5 and then
I get to keep it then I have this huge
square and yeah it just allows me to go
there which is unavoidable I guess so do
with us and now what is the thing I
think Bishop g5 looks like the most
natural move 94 on the cards do I just
take it off I think I can keep the
tension that's probably better
Queen g3 is also also a possibility but
it would be excellent just if I get 94
and he has to take with the bishop that
would basically end the game
[Music]
yeah I mean if it takes it's also pretty
awful if he has to take if we take it
with the night dad it will also not help
much
I'm I got drugged II one next
really 97 94
I don't know it's probably there were
probably direct winds but I let sit is
enough
it's got absolutely no current play
mmm okay night g7 night no and I know
this is not this is best but better than
before because okay this I didn't even
see you have to admit
okay now Queen cakes a simplest because
he cannot take on g7 Queen b7 it's Queen
to b7 ma'am
now that is that was 96 was was the
thing I guess that cost him at least I'm
better than ya the engine doesn't like
this all that much I'm a bit surprised
that it is so harsh about White's
position because I mean I have a hard
time to believe that white can be really
worse you know I mean I don't
III me believe that I don't have
anything but I'm not worse and now I did
get somewhat equal ish yeah not certain
maybe maybe here should do do something
differently get the immediate f5 I kind
of when I played Queen e1 I thought
didn't I recommend this but I couldn't
quite piece it together that's probably
not a bad choice I'm pushing this while
it's possible I mean black cannot really
take here this is not going to extend
that black has no King position anymore
and here this is a good counter play
with c5 King and we're still f5 okay
yeah I've failed probably wrongly I was
thinking take take take
James take take and I kind of stopped
you f6 is very strong well that's nice
that's a nice move this this is this and
white is completely winning that's nice
okay and so there were f5 a set is
stronger yeah then King edge one clearly
but this should be in a nice for Mia
night before like d4 seems to be better
now the capture and f5 is very strong
its most logically and getting at this
point there's a disaster multiple wins
probably Bishop age 494 yeah pretty okay
up to this point
finding the computer lines even before
the top top choice
f5 okay but it's it's it's a man
massively oh yeah from a huge choice
between many winning winning lines okay
guys thanks for watching